I'm just lost I got a really emotional
and important message from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys John and I
wanted to read it and then answer it and
I got a lot of comments with this one
really moved me and is is is really
important it's really important for you
guys to understand this because I know a
lot of you are going through it let me
read it here's a dilemma for you Eric
okay we know it's Evan right it's not
Eric I don't know I think I have an
entrepreneurial ATD I started a few
years ago thinking that I wanted to
start a shop to work on cars bikes and
so on I've been tinkering on cars from
the age of 12 I'm 22 now I went out and
got a job in industry really enjoyed it
ended up starting my own shop about five
months ago and now I couldn't be more
bored of it I still enjoyed working on
cars and it's always going to be a hobby
of mine but every day is becoming
tedious and annoying so I ended up
quitting the business I working for a
company doing the exact same thing which
is actually more fun that way for me
because I enjoy being around people and
the shopper hat was literally just me
and I had my girlfriend coming after her
job and helped do silly things but even
now I'm not truly satisfied I like the
feeling of owning my own business and
knowing that it's all under my control
of my own hands I really don't know why
I feel that way but it's just the way it
is I think I'm going to start heading in
the direction of being around people
maybe buying and selling items may be
some sort of retail business I might
start buying and selling instruments for
I've played music also for my whole life
I guess what I'm wrapping it all up to
question you is what do you think I
should do I feel like I'm never going to
find the right direction I'm really
hoping that all this pans out and I
enjoy the next path I tempted to go down
but everybody is telling me hey stick
with something and it's actually
starting to make me worry I do have to
settle down some point my life I have
bills and an apartment but I really
enjoyed cars really enjoy music really
enjoy buying and selling things retail
wise I enjoy being on people and enjoyed
festivals and festivities I'm just lost
in the sauce on what path to go down
any advice so it's a long message John
as you know at his wits and ease
all out there for you and you know I
really feel for John and and this is
such an important topic okay this is
such an important topic because most
people they get up and they drive to a
job that they hate and they're living
for the evenings and weekends right
that's eighty percent of America plus
they wake up they're driving to this
company that they can't stand and then
they're just they can't wait for
quitting time and they're waiting for
what they're gonna do on the weekends
that's when they live and and for me
that's not a way to live I don't want to
just live for my weekends in my evenings
I want to be doing meaningful important
work if that's running my own business
or if it's taking a job if that's what I
meant to do but I want to be doing
something where I feel like I'm having
an impact what I'm doing is important so
the path that you need to follow is this
there's three simple steps one Explorer
to follow the flow and three pivot okay
what does that mean let me break it down
one Explorer you got to explore things
okay you got to try stuff you don't know
if you're going to like something until
you actually go in and do it
you don't look at data and say well arm
this type of person so I'm going to go
into this type of job go and try and see
if it works if you like it right and
congratulations first of all for having
the guts to go out and launch your own
shop and say you know what I want to
explore this I'm going to go and do it
and so it didn't work and so you're
gonna go do something else
but you have to keep exploring and don't
listen to your friends and family who
say hey it's time to settle down now
it's time for you to join the rest of
the world and live a crappy life right
is that what you want to do so so it
didn't work out once you took one shot
and that's it you give up and you live
the life everybody else hates that's not
the answer you got to get up and try
again
explore and small starts start something
on a small level and just try it out
stop thinking about something and get
out of your head and start actually
doing something and see if you enjoy it
you might try something and you hate it
and now you know you have your answer
you may try something and you love it
and you want to do more and more and
more
you get obsessed with it that's number
two you follow your flow you see what
you love doing you're trying a bunch of
stuff right at this point you don't know
what to do go and try stuff you're going
to keep doing the stuff that you love to
do there's some things you're going to
try take wow this is awesome and you
want to keep doing it and keep doing it
Center the whole day is passed by like
what happened to my day it was amazing
you want to do it again you're obsessed
with you think about it when you're
sleeping maybe you wake up early the
next day because you can't wait to go
and do it again right so you're
following your flow if you get in that
zone you got to stay there that's where
the great stuff happens when you're
following your flow not doing some
crappy job that you don't like anymore
if it's tedious and boring don't do it
you think you're going to build a great
life doing stuff that's tedious and
boring no you got to do the stuff that
makes you come alive so you have to
follow your flow you explore you follow
the flow number three is pivot you might
find that after following your flow it
doesn't work out anymore the passion
goes away right you started your car
thing you thought hey this is great
this is what I always wanted to do you
tried five months later it's not working
out you pivot you go do something else
you start exploring again that's okay
sometimes that flow lasts for a month
six months a year a decade you know you
don't know how long it's gonna last
I'm making these videos okay let me tell
you two stories I'm making these videos
okay I got a whole bunch of stuff in my
career a new idea comes along I love to
try it just to explore I explore a whole
bunch of stuff most of it doesn't work
out sometimes I try something and and I
like it for a little bit and I continue
on doing it and then I get bored of it
so I either close it down or if it's
important to the company I give it to
somebody else too many choose I don't
want to touch it because if I was
continuing to do that my business
wouldn't grow because me doing stuff
that I hate or board up or tedious or
don't like anymore that's not going to
be me building a great company so I'm
making these videos I love making these
videos it's one of the favorite parts of
my week it's answering your questions
seeing what comes in and feeling like
hey I'm helping people out your comments
coming back is fuel for me every single
day maybe one day I'll get bored of it
if I don't like video day if I if it's
Wednesday
when I record all these videos and uh
man I got to do more videos this sucks
man hate this you think I'm going to
make great videos with that attitude No
so I would have to shut it down and that
would be very sad at least right now I
love the video so I'm going to keep
going for now but you will have that
moment where you make it tight or
something and it's okay to move on okay
let me tell you one more quick story
that I've told the forints of my videos
this applies not just a business but
what you do in your life and I remember
I've tried three activities recently
okay
dancing rock climbing and snowboarding
the rock climbing one I went rock
climbing somebody invited me so hey sure
I've never done rock climbing let me try
that I hated it
okay I hate rock climbing had a terrible
experience you know I'm afraid of
heights at all like looking down I don't
like feeling like I can't reach the next
thing the strap was anyway whatever I
didn't like it I'm not going to go back
again that's cool I'm okay with it I'm
okay with having tried it not having
this I wish I could do things I don't
have this I wish I could do list if I
want to do something I go out and try it
so rock climbing is not for me then I
tried snowboarding somebody said hey
join us for a snowboarding trip I've
never gone snowboarding hey why not
let's try it out and I loved it and and
I became obsessed with it the next week
I went on bought all my gear I bought my
own board the boots the hat the coat
everything I wanted and bought
everything I need to be snowboarding and
I would I would spend every day in the
winter snowboarding every single day I
went snowboarding because I loved it so
much I would be like waiting for
meetings to end so I can go snowboarding
it might even rush through video day
like guys can I got an hour I can go hit
the snowboarding hill there's one close
to where I live I loved it and that
lasted for two years and then in my
interests has started to fade it's
always gonna be part of me I think I
love snowboarding it's still great but
I'm not obsessed
I don't wake up you know in the more
like oh I can't wait to go snowboarding
right I'll I'll push a meeting so I can
go snowboarding right so the the passion
is faded the third one is salsa
and dancing salsa you look at it on
paper and it it's it was a stupid
decision for me to get into salsa right
I'm too tall
I took huge steps I have no dance
background I didn't understand the music
I don't speak the language I don't know
any of the moves I'm starting so late in
life like this is never going to be
something that would would on paper look
good for me to do right so this is um if
I went in thinking this is my next
business opportunity is my next love
that I'm going to fall in love with
alright the next thing that's going to
skyrocket me it would make any I'm
probably even trying because it didn't
make any sense logically but I went I
went to the first class and I just loved
it and I would go back and do more I
couldn't get enough sauce I'm listening
to the music and I'm watching the videos
and learning turn patterns the guy's
responsibility is to lead what I call
turn patents you're leading the moves
and I remember thinking that night about
moves that I can come up with and I
remember being in meetings with with
guys for business and I would imagine if
I took his hand and moved his arm like
this oh I could make this new turn
pattern and I'd like to zoom out of my
meeting and then come back because I was
thinking about salsa and it became this
passion it's been going 10 years now and
I'm an investor in the largest salsa
dance studio in Canada maybe North
America teach five six thousand students
a year how to dance salsa
it's a huge part of my life I'll DJ and
then teach some of the classes and it's
it's been awesome and so I'm following
the flow right I explored
I followed the flow and I haven't
pivoted off a salsa like I did off of
snowboarding because I still love it and
it's worked out for me and I would have
never thought about getting into that so
when you're first getting started right
we're in this stage now you don't know
what to do you feel this pressure that
you need to settle down you need to
figure out what you're going to do with
your life and it's all chaos and you
don't know what to do and when you force
yourself into a decision it's not going
to be a great one right you force
yourself to go get a job you're not
going to be great or happy in that life
right whenever you've got a gun to your
head to make a decision right now that's
never the best one you need to give
yourself the space
to explore the follow your flow and to
pivot and remember that all these people
who are trying to force you to make a
decision they hate their lives too
they're not doing anything great so why
are you taking advice from people who
haven't done great things in their life
you look at the people who've done great
things and a lot of them have bounced
from something to something to something
and explore it and fail and failed and
tried something it didn't work out
before they hit their thing that helps
them explode research famous
entrepreneurs look at the people who you
look up to and respect and learn from
their success this is where it comes
from if you want to be great you want to
help have a huge impact on the world you
want to live a fulfilled life then you
have to remember explore follow your
flow and pivot believe those are
watching and like the video support me
by clicking on the link in the
description leave a comment let me know
what you think and click on my face scar
to the channel if you want to see more
videos like this thank you so much I'll
see you soon